[Musique]
bonjour là bonjour pauline à la une de
la presse ce matin les nouvelles menaces
de vladimir poutine le président russe
qui se dit prêt désormais à cesser
toutes les livraisons d'hydrocarbures à
l'europe la guerre de l'énergie franchir
un nouveau palier d'après les échos le
président russe a également attaquer
l'occident collectif accusé de maintenir
un vieil ordre du monde je le cite au
détriment du reste de la planète le
patron du kremlin a salué en revanche le
rôle croissant de la région asie
pacifique et le partenariat stratégique
entre la russie et la chine un discours
reçu cinq sur cinq à pékin ou de global
times confirme la montée en puissance de
la coopération avec moscou pour contrer
je sais toujours l'hégémonie américaine
la russie et la chine vont renforcer
leurs liens dans un monde multipolaire
claironne le journal qui annonce une
rencontre la semaine prochaine entre
vladimir poutine et chez jean ping la
première depuis le début de la guerre en
ukraine accueil très favorable également
en inde narindra maudit soutient les
liens économiques et énergétiques avec
la russie
india le premier ministre a répété hier
le soutien de new delhi aux efforts
pacifiques pour mettre fin au conflit en
ukraine et indiqué également que le
manque d'approvisionnement en céréales
en grès et hydrocarbures est une
préoccupation majeure pour les pays en
développement au brésil des centaines de
milliers manifestants enrayer les rues
hier à l'occasion du ces des
célébrations du bicentenaire de
l'indépendance du pays à trois semaines
du premier tour de la présidentielle
vous l'avez évoqué premier tour qui
opposera à germolles sonar haut à l'ex
président lula faut il est sympa or
estime que l'actuel président a cherché
à transformer ces célébrations
rassemblements électoraux d'après le
journal boll sonar a répété à cette
occasion ses menaces de coups d'état en
cas d'échec électoral et ja rbl sonar ou
dans un petit porte une grande
responsabilité dans la destruction de la
forêt amazonienne d'après des dirigeants
indigènes touchées par des incendies
ravageurs depuis le mois dernier la plus
grande forêt tropicale du monde a vu un
quart de ses 550 millions d'hectares
irrigués
humblement détruits selon ces
responsables cités par libération les
collègues pinho site précise que ces
destructions concerne particulièrement
un arc qui va du nord du brésil au
sud-ouest de la forêt amazonienne une
zone déjà touchée par une déforestation
importantes liées au développement de
l'agriculture industrielle et l'élevage
depuis les années 70 cet expert met en
cause les effets combinés de cette
déforestation et du changement
climatique aggravée selon lui par la
politique d' impunité conduite sous
gerbaud le sonar au problème de la
déforestation qui touche aussi désormais
une partie de l'europe centrale de
l'europe du nord oui pardonnez moi j'ai
oublié de vous signaler au sujet de
cette déforestation les ravageurs qui
ont lieu dans la forêt amazonienne ce
dessin de coco publié également par
libération qui montre concrètement les
effets de des incendies de la
déforestation en général un quart de la
forêt amazonienne disparu à jamais ce
donc un quart du tableau on en vient
donc à ce problème qui touche aussi
désormais une partie de l'europe
centrale et de l'europe du nord une
enquête du new york times pauline révèle
comment des pays comme l'estonie la
hongrie la roumanie mais également la
finlande ont considérablement développer
l'exploitation forestière depuis une
dizaine d'années un essor qui a été
largement subventionnés par l'union
européenne qui souhaitait promouvoir à
l'époque les alternatives au charbon et
au gaz le bois étant qualifié d'
énergies renouvelables parce que les
arbres finissent par pousser selon de
new yok times cette politique a eu un
tel succès que le bois est aujourd'hui
la première source d'énergie dites
renouvelables donc en europe loin devant
l'éolien et le solaire le problème c'est
que cette source d'énergie est elle
aussi très polluante et celle agence de
recherche scientifique de lieux qui le
dit elle-même sans compter et bien que
cette exploitation tous azimuts en
traîne aussi la destruction des
dernières forêts sauvages d'europe la
question d'environnement qui fera
certainement partie des sujets débattus
au sein du conseil national de la
refondation lancé aujourd'hui par le
président français emmanuel macron ce
sens et vous l'avez d'illustrer la
nouvelle une méthode présidentielle pour
revivifier la démocratie et co
construire les politiques publiques je
cite le président l'initiative est
globalement accueillent avec scepticisme
de l'opinion estime que ce cnr a surtout
aurait surtout pour but de conjurer la
défiance à l'égard d' emmanuel macron je
voulais m'inspirer du conseil national
de la résistance lui fait dire qu'à
qu'un dans libération le mythique cnr
issu de la libération sauf que
l'opposition a pris le maquis relève la
première ministre d'un côté par
l'opposition le président sera même au
bord du vide
à en croire libération qui trouvent que
ce cnr a comme un air de déjà vu la
convention citoyenne pour le climat ou
ou encore les fameuses agora poste gilet
jaune pour la 3 la démarche des manuels
macron paraît certes bouillonne n'est
pas dénué de calcul mais l'intention
serait louable le journal salue un pari
démocratique face auquel il invite
chacun à ne pas en rester aux postures
ou au procès d'intention en 1re armes
aux raisons de refuser le dialogue
professe le journal merci hélène pour
cette revue de presse